Chris waters here with a gamespot news
update the rumors that halo 2 was
getting an HD remake may be just the tip
of the iceberg now there are rumors that
HD versions of halos 1 through 4 are
coming to the Xbox one this collection
would be intended to quote refresh
audiences memories of Master Chief prior
to the release of halo 5 according to
tech blog and gadget so there is
speculation that halo ODST and halo
reach will not be included no details
are provided on whether the game will be
a physical disc release or digital
download nor is there any indication
what the frame rate or resolutions will
be the developer of this remastered
collection is unknown but saber
interactive helped 343 industries on
2011's halo combat evolved anniversary
edition and they're working on an
unannounced Xbox one game currently so
it's a good bet that's the halo
collection of course halo 5 was just
announced for release in 2015 and during
her statement Bonnie Ross of 343
industries also said that that journey
definitely begins in 2014 with a giant
leap rather than one small step so as
soon as this fall you could be getting
back into halo combat evolved for the
second third time another new platform I
guess playing some halo 2 is the arbiter
meeting that grave mind weirdo bringing
the flood to earth and halo 3 waking up
after space sleep in Halo four with sexy
Cortana model thing I don't know III is
gonna be when we're gonna find out more
about this folks as Bonnie Ross has said
there press briefing is going to contain
all sorts of information about that and
we'll be bringing it to you right here
on gamespot